الطوارئ في تركيا لمده ثلاثه اشهر في
المناطق المنكوبه في سوريا المجاوره
ارتفعت حصيله الضحايا لاكثر من 2500 قتيل
والاصابات تخطت الخمسه الاف جريح جراء
الزلزال والتوابعك فرق الانقاذ تسابق
الزمن لانتشال الضحايا والعالقين تحت
انقاض الابنيه التي دمرها زلزال تركيا
وسوريا
[موسيقى]
ونتابع معكم التحديثات والعواجل بارتفاع
حصيله ضحايا الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا الان
لاكثر من 9500 قتل كاميرا العربيه ايضا
كانت رصدت تداعيات الزلزال تركيا في
انطاكيا
واظهرت انهيار المنازل وعمليات رفع
الانقاذ الانقاض في محاولات مستمره لانقاذ
الضحايا والعالقين جراء هذه الهزه الارضيه
العنيفه
[موسيقى]
وفي تركيا تستعيد فرق لانقاذ المدني
بالكلاب المدربه على عمليات البحث
والانقاذ في الوصول الى الناجين المحاصرين
تحت ركامل ابنيه المهذبه جراء الزلزال
الذي شهدته البلاد
مباشره الى غاز عنتاب وهذا المؤتمر الصحفي
لوزير البيئه والاعمار التركي
[موسيقى]
في مناطق الزلزال وايضا هناك مخيمات نقوم
بانشائها
بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك خيم ننشئها حسب
المكان حسب ما تسمح لنا المنطقه من مكان
لنصب هذه الخيم وايضا المراكز المخيمات
المؤقته الان نعمل على تجهيز
البناء التحتيه لتامين الحاويات
[موسيقى]
من الزلازل بالاضافه الى اننا نعمل الان
اداره الاسكان التركيه
من اجل بناء مساكن ايضا هنا الان
لاضافتها الى الحاويات وبشكل مؤقت دون ان
تمنع هذه الحاويات وهذه المساكن الى
عمليات البحث والانقاذ وايضا نعمل مع مع
اداره الاسكان على بناء منازل دائما الان
نخطط
طريقه او كيفيه اعاده اعمار هذه المنطقه
باسرع وقتا ممكن
لحصول الناجين من هذه الزلازل الى مئوي
دائمه وليس مؤقته فقط الان لدينا
مطابخ متحركه في غازي عنتاب في مناطق
عديده من غازي عنتاب المتضرره من الزلازل
لتقديم الطعام الساخن الى الناجين من
الزلازل هناك ايضا حول المدن نقوم تقديم
الحساء وايضا الماكولات الساخنه بشكل
مستمر الى ان جين من الزلازل نستخدم ايضا
بعض المراكز الثقافيه وبعض الملاعب وبعض
المراكز الاخرى منها الرياضيه ومنها
ثقافيه ومنها تخدم مصالح اخرى في التعليم
مثلا او ما شابه الجميع الان يتحرك وايانا
من اجل تقديم كل الخدمات الممكنه من اذى
العزم لكل من يتواجد هناك الان
يتم العمل في كل المناطق التي تضررت تضررت
من الزلازل منطقه لمصر اليها في غازي
عنتاب لحد الان
وسنتكاتف
ونستمر بعمليات البحث والانقاذ
بشكل دقيق وسننقذ
العالقين وانتشار العالقين تحت الانقاذ
نتمكن من انقاذ اكبر عدد ممكن من هذه
الانقاذ نستمر طبعا
بعملياتنا رغم وجود ظروف
الجويه الصعبه جدا هناك ثلوج هناك امطار
هناك عواصف كما تعلمون في فصل الشتاء
الجنوب يعيشوها بشكل قاسي نحن الان نرى ان
هناك ايضا حاجه ماسه للبطاريات وبالتالي
ايضا افاد
ينسق كيفيه نقل هذه المواد الى الناجينه
من
الزلازل ونتابع هذه العمليه ايضا عن كتب
طبعا باذنه تعالى سنتكاتف وسنتضامن
كل المساعدات الممكنه نحن دوله قويه
وشعبنا قوي
ونحن نشكر التضامن العالمي وايانا ونحن
ايضا كنا قد قدمنا هذا
التضامن مع كل الدول المتضرره من اي كارثه
حصلت في اي حال حصلت نحن نتقدم بالتعاجي
للشعب التركي ونتمنى الشفاء العاجل للجرحى
وشكرا
انا واياكم المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير البيع
والاعمار التركي
الذي قال فيه بان سلطات التركيه تعمل على
تجهيز البنى التحتيه للحاويات وكذلك
المسائل المساكن المؤقته
والمخيمات لواء المهاجرين والمشردين
والنازحين
وهناك عمل ايضا على ايضا اعاده الكهرباء
الى المناطق المتضرره بشكل تدريجي سيتم
توفير الكهرباء اعتبارا من مساء اليوم من
هاتاي تركيا وهي احدى المناطق المتضرره
جراء هذا الزلزال ينضم الينا منفذ العربيه
عمار الهندي عمار كيف تصف الصوره الان
اهلا خالد
لم اسمع السؤال تصف المشهد حيث انت الان
وكيف تجري عمليات الانقاذ بالنسبه للفرق
الموجوده حيث
اسعاف طبعا هنالك المئات من سيارات
الاسعاف التي تنقل للاسف جثامين القتلى
التي يتم يعني اخراجها من تحت الانقاذ
الدمار هائل في كل مكان هذه المدينه تعتبر
المدينه الاكثر دمارا من المدن التي تضررت
بدراء هذا الزلزال انا ساسير بالكاميرا
سالتفت انا والزميل المصور يعني حتى تشاهد
الكاميرا كيف يبدو الدمار في كل مكان في
هذه المدينه نحن وسط انطاكيا عاصمه ولايه
هاتاي الاكثر دماارا هنالك طبعا عشرات بل
المئات من المباني التي حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يتم اخراج
العالقين فيها سواء يعني كانوا على قيد
الحياه او او اموات للاسف يعني هنالك
جثامين تخرج تباعا من هذه المباني التي
يتم تتم فيها اعمال
الانقاذ وازاله الانقاض تاسير ايضا خالد
بالك حتى تشاهد كميه الدمار الهائل طبعا
هنالك مستشفى في نفس الشارع الذي انا
اتواجد فيه
تدمرت بالكامل على تقريبا 10 او 8 كيلو
ثمان كيلو مترات على بعد ثمانيه كيلو
مترات من هنا كانت تعمل مستشفى خاص كانت
تعمل وهي مدمره بالكامل هنالك استنفار
كبير هذا المبنى مثلا الذي يظهر امامك في
الصوره قبل قليل كانوا استخرجوا منه جثث
للسيدات يعني للاسف فارقوا الحياه تحت
الانقاض من جراء هذا الانهيار هنالك اعداد
كبيره جدا من المباني المنهاره جزئيا
وبالتالي هنالك خشيه حقيقيه من الهزات
الارتداديه التي تحدث اليوم صباحا ونحن
يعني بيتنا هذه الليله في السياره والجميع
هنا يعني يبات في سيارتهم لانه تعرف هنالك
خوف اساسا من المبيت داخل المباني شعرنا
بشكل كبير جدا بالهزه التي حدثت اليوم
صباحا في في هاتاي في انطاكيا وسط مدينه
هات طبعا هنالك طائرات مروحيه عسكريه تحلق
على مستويات منخفضه هنا في المدينه تنقل
على ما يبدو مساعدات على الجانب الاخر
ايضا من حيث اقف هنالك دمار هائل في
المباني هنالك طبعا فرق متطوعين تاتي
تباعا واليات تاتي تباعا كنت يعني احنا
وصلناها ليله امس فجرا كنت ايضا شرحت بان
الناس هنا كانت تشتكي بانه عمليات الانقاذ
تاخرت قليلا على هاتاي وهنالك من يبرر
بانه البلاد كلها في صدمه كبيره من جراء
ما حدث كميه الدمار هائل جدا وبالتالي هم
في يعني هنالك عدم قدره على تلبيه جميع
المباني المنهاره التي
يتواجد فيها
تحت الانقاض اشخاص لا زالوا حتى هذه
اللحظه على كما تعلم يعني اعداد القتلى
للاسف ترتفع مع كل ساعه لانه عمليات البحث
هذه الطائره عسكريه مثلا تحلق على مستوى
منخفض فوق مدينه هاتاي لا ندري هي تنقل
مساعدات ام جرح مثلا لانه لانه يتم نقل
الجرحى من هذه المدينه الى مستشفيات مثلا
مدينه اضنه الاقل تضررا من هاتاي يمكن
القول بانه هذه المدينه خالد منكوبه
بالكامل فعلا يعني اينما اينما نظرت انت
هنالك مباني مدمره بشكل كامل وهنالك طبعا
يعني حاله شهاده اشخاص كانوا للاسف تبلغوا
بان ذويهم يعني خفرقوا الحياه تحت الانقاذ
هناك حالات يعني انهيار وحزن شديد وبكاء
طبعا وهذا طبيعي ولكن السؤال الاكبر كم
تبقى من الاشخاص خالد تحت الانقاض يعني
نحن نعلم ارقام القتلى نعلم ارقام الجرحى
ولكن السؤال الذي يصعب تنبا باجابته او
حتى هذه اللحظه كم عدد الاشخاص الذين في
عموم تركيا لا يزال تحت الانقاض وكم
يستغرق تستغرق عمليات البحث ورفع الانقاض
من وقت ولكن ربما قرار حاله طوارئ الذي
تحدثت عنه لمده ثلاثه اشهر يجيب على هذا
السؤال بان هذه العمليات ربما تحتاج الى
وقت وقت كبير كما تعلم ايضا نحن انهينا
يومين مع فجر هذا اليوم ودخلنا في اليوم
الثالث وهنالك حاله من الاستياء بانه وخوف
كبير على من كان على قيد الحياه بانه
الوقت ليس في صالحه وهذا هذه الحرب مع
الوقت بلا فرق الانقاذ الجميع هنا طبعا
الجيش يشارك الامن يشارك الدفاع المدني
متطوعين من عموم المناطق حتى يعني اشخاص
سوريين كانوا يقيمين هنا كلهم تطوعوا
للبحث تحت الانقاض ويعني
لعلهم يجدوا اشخاصا لا زالوا على قيد
الحياه في هاتاي لم تسجل اي حالات سوى
ليله امس واخرجوا رجلا مسنا من مبنى هنا
مع ساعات الفجر كان لا يزال على قيد
الحياه ولم يصاب باي اذى لانه كان محاصر
تحت الانقاض عمار نحن نتابع معك
انا سكت نعم انا سكت لان المبنى الذي يظهر
امامك تفضل
خالد هم ينادون الان في المبنى الذي يظهر
امامك هنالك اصوات على ما يبدو لاحياء
فبالتالي هذا الصمت الذي تشاهده الجميع
صمت الان لانهم يحاولون استماع ما اذا كان
هنالك اشخاص فعلا انقاذ او لا ينادون
عليهم وبالتالي هذا ما يحدث يعني هذا
المشهد خالد يختزل لك كل ما يحدث في تركيا
الان هذا يتكرر الان عشرات الالاف المرات
اشخاص يحاولون ان يستمعوا الى صوت واحد
يدل على شخص لا يزال معك لاحقا شكرا جزيلا
لك متابعه ايضا هذه التغطيه من مدينه
هاتاي المنكوبه التي تحولت ايضا او ان
نتحول الى منطقه اديمان التركيه ايضا في
عمليات الانقاذ الدراماتيكيه التي تجري
الان حيث تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من اخراج ام
وطفلها البالغ من العمر 3 سنوات من تحت
الانقاض بعد 47 ساعه من وق
ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
كذلك نشرت في الانقاذ المدني في تركيا
فيديو لانقاذ طفل كان نائما لحظه انقاذه
ما تسبب بخوف وصدمه للطفل الذي بقي ساعات
طويله تحت
[موسيقى]
بعد انتشاري مقطع فيديو ايضا لانقاذ
مولوده حديثه من تحت الانقاد في سوريا كاد
الطبيب الذي يشرف على صحتها ان الطفله
بحاله مستقره الان بعد توفير العلاج
المناسب لها
[موسيقى]
وصلتنا هاي البنت مبارح الساعه ثلاثه بعد
الظهر مع كدمات عديده ومع ساحجات كامل
جسمها البنت
شديد تم تطفيء التطبيق
[موسيقى]
الجيش التركي بدوره يواصل ايضا عمليات
الاجلاء لضحايا الزلزال بطائراته العسكريه
من المناطق المتضرره في كل من اضنه
وملاطيا الى العاصمه انقره
[موسيقى]
هذا ويكافح المئات من الاتراك في المخيمات
المؤقته وسط البرد القارس وتساقط الثلوج
الذين اضطروا ايضا لسكن في خيم بسيطه شيدت
بسرعه لاحتوائهم بعد تدمر منازلهم جراء
الزلزال
[موسيقى]
اذهب الى اضنه الان الى زيدان زين كل
مراسل العربيه زيدان مرحبا بك زيدان انت
كيف تصف لنا المشهد كيف تسير عمليات
الانقاذ
الفريق اجنبي دخل مع كلاب مدربه الان فريق
على ما اعتقد من روسيا سيدخل ايضا هناك
لديه اجهزه متقدمه للكشف عن الاصوات او عن
اي ارتدادات يمكن ان تؤدي الى بارقه امل
او تعطي بارقه امل في في عمليات البحث
فريق الانقاذ او فريق المختص الذي دخل قبل
قليل حدد نقطه معينه سنحاول رصدها الان
عبر الكاميرا هذه النقطه طلب من العمال
الحفر فيها وبتاني شديد يعني الحفر لا
يقوم بالاليات الثقيله انما باليات بسيطه
وبتاني شديد كما نشاهد في هذه اللقطه على
شاشه العربيه هذه النقطه تحديدا التي تظهر
على الشاشه هي هنا كانت الكلاب المدربه
تشير الى وجود شيء ما لا نعلم هل هم احياء
ام هناك جثث تستمر العمليات الخبراء طلبوا
من العمال البحث في هذه الن نامل كما كل
الموجودين هنا في هذا الموقع ان يكون هناك
ان شاء الله احياء ما زالوا طبعا دخلنا
اليوم الثالث العامل عامل الوقت هو ليس في
مصلحه احد سواء كان هناك ناجين تحت
الانقاض او الذين يعملون هنا في هذا
الموقع وفي مواقع اخرى في اضنه وفي
الولايات المنكوبه الاخرى
زيدان وانت في اضنه
يعني كم عدد البنايات المدمره التي مررت
بها ما حجم هذه الفرق الموجوده التي تقوم
بعمليات الانقاذ مدى توفر المعدات اللازمه
ايضا
لها معدات المطلوبه ايضا لانتشال الجثث
الانتشار العالقين من تحت هذه المباني
المدمر
نعم خالد اظن اضافه الى ولايات ديار بكر
وشاني اورفا وكل صيام اقل المدن تضررا
بهذا الزلزال لا يمكن مقارنه المشهد هنا
بهاتاي التي
احياء بالكامل هبطت الان نتحدث هنا في
موقع هبط هذا المبنى لحسن الحظ المباني
المجاوره سلمت لكن هي مهدده ايضا
بالانهيار ساحاول من زميلي اطلب من زميلي
ان يصور لنا المبنى المجاور الذي نقف
بقربه بقربه بالضبط يعني نحن على بعد
اربعه او خمسه امتار فقط من هذا المبنى
كما تشاهد هناك تشققات فهذا المبنى ايضا
مكون من اربعه عشر طالقا تشققات انا حسب
ما اشاهد حتى الطابق الثالث منذ من هنا من
الارضيه حتى الطابق الثالث هناك تشققات
بالتالي هذا المبنى معرض للانهيار في اي
لحظه في حال كان هناك هزات ارتداديه قويه
حتى يعني ضجيج هذا الاليات كما اخ قبل
قليل احد عمال الانقاذ ربما يؤثر بشكل
سلبا سلبي لذلك العمل يتم بدقه وتاني شديد
حتى لا يؤدي العمل او التسارع العمل
المفرط والاستعجال الى انهيارات جديده
لذلك العمل يتم بتاني شديد حقيقه خالد نحن
منذ يوم امس وحتى هذا اليوم نتابع العمل
هنا في هذا الموقع لحظه بلحظه بدقيقه
بدقيقه كل ساعه تقريبا يصل فرق انقاذ
استطيع ان اؤكد فعلا ان الاعداد الموجوده
اليوم في هذا الموقع هي ضعف العدد الموجود
يوم امس وهذا ما كان تؤكد عليه السلطات
التركيه من ان اعداد فرق الانقاذ هذا
اليوم وهو اليوم الحاسم الذي ترى فيه
الحكومه التركيه انها الفرصه الاخيره
للعثور على الناجين
ان قدر لهم ان شاء الله
الحياه والصبر في هذه الظروف الجويه
الصعبه لذلك كثفت من جهودها بشكل كامل
دفعت بكل طاقاتها
الفرق الموجوده سواء كان من كوادر طبيه او
فرق انقاذ او حتى عمال مناجم تم جلبهم الى
هذه المناطق طبعا كما قلت اظن اقل تضررا
لا نشاهد الموجوده في هاتاي احياء بالكامل
مدمره
دمار في كل مكان لا هنا دمار في بعض
المواقع وفي بعض الاحياء
وايضا الشرطه تحيط بهذه الابنيه بشكل كامل
طبعا في اضنه لا يوجد مشكله في توفر
المعدات في اجابه على سؤالك خالد لان مطار
اضنه قريب بالنسبه
للمعدات الخفيفه اما الاليات الثقيله ايضا
الطريق من انقره الى اضنه مفتوح بشكل كامل
لا توجد في اي مشكله سوى بعض الثغرات بسبب
تراكم الثلوج في بعض المناطق لا يوجد اي
انهيار في في الطريق المقدمه بين اسطنبول
ثم انقره واضنه وبالتالي اضن هي نقطه مرور
لهذه الاليات الضخمه الى بقيه الولايات
الى هاتاي او الى غاز عنتاب وكهرمان مرعش
في اضنه لا توجد هذه المشكله انما اضن هي
الان مركز دعم لوجستي تقريبا لباقي
الولايات كما اكد نائب الرئيس التركي
فؤاد يوم امس المباني التي صورتها قبل
قليل زيدان
التي تعاني ربما من تشققات الجراء الزلزال
يعني هل تم اخلاء هذه المباني تماما من
ساكنها
نعم خالد بالضبط
سنعيد اللقطه الى هذه المباني المهدده
بالانهيار طبعا هذه المباني
اخليت تماما من السكان تم نقل كل سكان هذه
المباني اضافه الى الناجين من هذا المبنى
المدمر بعد علاجهم الى مخيمات مؤقته هنا
بالقرب من هذا المكان الذي نتواجد فيه
شهاده احد المخيمات كان في سوق شعبي يدعى
هنا في تركيا بالبازار هيئه الطوارئ
والكوارث التركيه افاد وضعت في عشرات
الخيام لاستقبال
الناجين وايضا الساكنين في هذه المباني
الشرطه ايضا فرضت طوقا امنيا على هذه
المباني ممنوع الدخول اي شخص الى هذه
المباني وحتى الماره يعني الشارع الملاصق
لهذه المباني قد تم
اغلاقه بشكل كامل الا من المعدات والاليات
والسيارات الاسعاف وسيارات نقل
جثث والموتى التي تاتي بشكل يعني بين فينه
واخره عندما يتم انتشار الجثث لذلك هناك
يعني احتياطات امنيه في محيط المباني هذا
هذه المباني المهدده بالانهيار كما نتابع
الان عمليات الانقاذ تستمر في النقطه التي
حددها فريق الخبراء يعني ما زال امل هناك
بالوصول الى ناجين سنحاول تصوير بعض من
الفريق الذي كان قبل قليل يشرق على هذا
العمل مع الفريق الكلاب
المدربه هذا
كما تشاهدون عبر شاشه العربيه هناك كلاب
مدربه مع هذا الفريق كانت تجوب المكان
وتبحث عن اشخاص ما زالوا على قيد الحياه
الان هم ابتعدوا وافسحوا المجال لبقيه
المتطوعين والعمال للحفر بالنقاط التي
حددوها على وجه التحديد والتي يعتقد بوجود
ناجين
زيدان محدده من قبل الفريق الخبراء قبل
هذا الفريق الان فيما يتعلق بهذه البنايه
من هذا الموقع نعم نعم من هذا
نعم نعم من هذا الموقع تم انتشار خمسه
اشخاص ناجين يوم امس لكن هذا الحديث كان
خلال ساعات النهار يعني في المساء عندما
وصلنا كان هناك اصوات لاشخاص تحت الركام
لكن لم يتم اخراج ناجين صباح هذا اليوم
وصلوا الى نقطه واستطاعوا فتح ثغره
والوصول الى بعض الجثث لكن كما ذكرت اليوم
الان المحاوله التركيز اكثر على وصول الى
ناجين على قيد الحياه التركيز لذلك يعني
مع شكوك فريق الانقاذ بوجود
ناجين تم استدعاء كل
الخبراء تقريبا الذي المتاحين حاليا هنا
في ولايه اضنه الى هذا الموقع وكما ذكرت
هذا فريق وهناك فريق اخر روسي يحاول ان
ينتظر ان تنجلي او ان يتم الحفر بشكل او
باخر حتى يدخل الى الموقع
الان الفريق
الفريق اخر الان يدخل الى هذا الموقع كما
تشاهدون على الشاشه فريق خبراء مختص من
خارج تركيا على ما اعتقد هذا فريق روسي
الان يدخل الى الموقع للمشاركه في عمليات
التنقيب
او فريق من اذربيجان عفوا من اذربيجان
الفريق الذي يدخل الان الى هذا الموقع
سيشارك في العمليات
والمساعده نامل ان تتكلم كل هذه الجهود
حقيقه جهود صعبه
نعم امكانيات متوفره لكن العمل دقيق جدا
لا يمكن العمل بشكل عشوائي او بشكل
تلقائي يجب ان يكون ضمن شروط محدده وشروط
قاسيه للعمل كل هذه الظروف الصعبه وكل هذه
الشروط يرافقها طقس سيء جدا حراره متدنيه
بشكل كبير الجو بارد جدا وهذا يعني مشكله
لعمال الانقاذ دائما هناك نيران تشعر
يشعلها متطوعون
للتدفئه نشاهد عديد الاشخاص يعملون قليلا
ثم ياتوا الى هاته النيران لتلقي بعض
الدفع من ثم العوده الى مكان العمل العمل
لم يتوقف ابدا ابدا خلال الايام الماضيه
فريق يرتاح وفريق اخر يواصل العمل هذا
الموقع لم يغادره ابدا
لم تغادروا ابدا فرق الانقاذ كما نتابع
معك خالد في اي يعني المبنى كان كبيرا قبل
لذلك من المتوقع ان هناك عائلات كان
نعم نعم بالضبط بالضبط على كل حال
من قبل اداره الكوارث التركيه زيدان تقول
ان عدد قتل زلزال ارتفع الى
7,18 حتى الان يعني هذه اخر التحديثات هذه
اخر الارقام المعلنه من قبل الحكومه
التركيه حول ضحايا هذا الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب بعض المناطق الجنوبيه في تركيا
تحدثت زيدان على ان اضن يعني بمثابه مركز
الدعم اللوجستي كما قلته كما وصفته
بالنسبه للكثير من الولايات والمناطق التي
تعاني والتي يمكن ان يقول بان الدمار واضح
وشديد وقوي كما تابعنا قبل قليل على سبيل
المثال من هاتاي مع زميلنا عمار الهندي
عمار كان يقول بانه
المراكز الرعايه الصحيه هناك والمستشفيات
غير مؤهله للتعامل مع الحالات وبالتالي
يتم نقل الكثير من الحالات الى مستشفيات
ومراكز موجوده في في الظن
نعم بالضبط خالد ومن اظن يتم التعاطي مع
الحالات الحرجه ونقل الحارات الحالات
الحرجه عفوا الى انقره والى اسطنبول الى
المدن الطبيه التي جهزت
للتعاطي مع هذه الحالات وايضا هناك مدينه
طبيه في اضنه ومدينه طبيه في مدينه مرسين
القريبه او المجاوره لاضنه في حال لم يتم
استيعاب الحالات في كلتا
المدينتين اضنه او مرسين نقلهم جوا الى
انقره او
اسطنبول كما نتابع الشرطه تطلب من الجميع
حتى تطلب منا الاخلاء هذا المكان
الشرطه الان تطلب من الجميع الابتعاد عن
هذا المكان لكن سنحاول الان بعد قليل ان
نغادر المكان بعد انتهاء هذا المباشر معكم
خالد اعطونا بعض الوقت الاضافي مشكورين
عناصر الشرطه حتى الصحفيين جميعهم يغادرون
هذا المكان يبدو ان العمليه وصلت الى
مرحله حساسه تم اخلاء الموقع بشكل كبير
لكن نواصل طالما اخذنا الاذن ببعض الدقائق
الاضافيه كما تلاحظون يعني خالد
كنا نتحدث عن ان فعلا اضنه هي مركز
استقبال
للجرحى والمصابين ومن ثم يتم اجلؤهم الى
اسطنبول وانقره بعد ايضا ليست فقط مركز
نقل للمصابين ايضا مركز نقل للمساعدات
يعني يوم امس عندما وصلنا مطار اضنه مساء
امس كان هناك الان خالد هذه لحظات سيتم
على ما اعتقد تحريك وهذا المشهد يتكرر
بشكل دائم سيتم رفع هذا هذه الكتله
الخرسانيه الضخمه نامل ان يكون تحت هذه
الكتله الخرسانيه الضخمه
اينجين يتم ابعاد العناصر بشكل كامل لذلك
الان
باتت الصوره واضحه لدينا تم ابعاد الكل
واخلاء هذا المكان عند رفع هذه الكتله
نامل ان لا يكون هناك اي انهيارات جديده
في هذه النقطه او هذا الموقع لذلك تم
ابعاد الجميع
ومن ثم سيتم ارسالهم الى بقيه المناطق
المنكوبه ليساعد حسم عالمنا ان حسب ما
علمنا ان عدد عمال الانقاذ وصل يوم امس
الى الف عفوا عمال المناجم الذين تم
استخدامهم وصل الى 2000 عامل وسيتم
تدعيمهم ايضا اليوم ب 500 بشكل عاجل يرتفع
عدد الى 2500 عام من عمان مهاجم هذه طبعا
اضافه الى عشرات الالاف من المتطوعين
وعمال الانقاذ الاتراك والالاف من عمال او
من الخبراء الاجانب يبدو الان انه تم
تحرير الكتله الخرسانيه وسيتم البدء
برفعها الان كما تشاهدون
سيتم رفع هذه الكتله ويتم رفع هذه الكتله
الخرسانيه الضخمه جدا من قبل اليتين
والان
نامل ان تكون هناك تحت هذه الكتله اشخاص
او ناجين
يتم التعاطي مع هذا الموضوع ببطء شديد
وهدوء شديد حتى لا تنهار الان يطلبون
التوقف سيبحثون قليلا
يحاولون التاكد فيما
اذا كان هناك اشخاص ان كان على قيد الحياه
او جثث
العمال يتاكدون ومن ثم ستتواصل العمليه في
حال لم يكن هناك اي شيء
كما تشاهد خالد متابع هذه اللحظه
على قدم وساق مسابقه للزمن من قبل هذه
الطرق
الان يتم تحريك هذه الكتله الاسمنتيه ربما
بدقه نظرا لامكانيه يعني تاثير على كل هذه
الجهود
نعم نعم يعني السلطات تركيا تعتقد ان هذا
اليوم هو يوم حاسم يعني من استطاع الصمود
لهذا اليوم من العالقين تحت الانقاض ربما
لا يصمد لاكثر من ذلك لذا تم تكثيف
الكوادر
وتم ابعاد تعزيز الكوادر تقريبا تمت
مضاعفه الكوادر في هذا في اضنه وفي كل
الولايات تحديدا فيها تاي وفي كهرمان مرعش
من اجل الوصول هذا اليوم الى اكبر عدد من
الناجين او العالقين تحت الانقاض وهم على
قيد الحياه طبعا يعني المشكله الاساسيه
خالد لا يمكن التكهن باعداد المحقودين لا
يمكن التكهم باعداد العالقين تحت هذه
الانقاض ليتم حصر الاضرار لا يمكن هذا
الموضوع يتطلب وقت وزمن طويل جدا من
الانتظار لا يعني حاليا نحن وايضا السلطات
التركيه الان تنمت ازاله هذه الكتله
وسيتم بعد قليل التنقيب تحت هذه الكتله
هذه الكتله التي طلب فريق الخبراء من عمال
الانقاذ الان
يكمل عمال الانقاذ
يبداون بالحفر بعد ازاله هذه الكتله
الخرسانيه كما تشاهد يعني الموضوع صعب صعب
صعب خالد حقيقه الموضوع صعب والمشكله لا
يعلمون كم عدد الاشخاص الموجودين تحت هذه
الانقاض ان كانوا على قيد الحياه سواء
كانوا على قيد الحياه او جثث حتى يتم
انتشاله هذه الجثث كل ما يمكن معرفته هو
الاشخاص الذين يتم اخراجهم اما احياء
فيضاف الى المصابين الى حصيه المضافين او
الناجين واما جثث يضاف الى اعداد الاشخاص
الذين قضوا في هذا الزلزال لذلك يعني
حقيقه يعني هم في سباق مع الزمن سواء كان
هنا فريق الانقاذ او السلطات التركيه او
كل الدوله التي تحاول
بذل كل الجهود يعني حقيقه نعم هناك عوامل
اثرت سلبا على عمليات الانقاذ نتحدث خصوصا
في هاتاي وفي كهرباء لان حجم الدمار كبير
حجم الكارثه كبيره يعني كما قال الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان يوم امس ان اكبر
كارثه شاهدتها تركيا والمنطقه وربما هي من
اكبر الكوارث على مستوى العالم ان يضرب
زلزال عشر ولايات في مناطق جغرافيه واسعه
يقطن هذه الولايات نتحدث فقط عن تركيا
الان يقتل هذه الولايات اكثر من 13 مليون
ايضا في الجانب الاخر من سوريا يعني في
سوريا مع الاسف في شمال سوريا كل هذه
الامكانيات التي نشاهدها هنا الان غير
موجوده هناك عمال الانقاذ اولا اعدادهم
قليله ويعملون باليات وامكانيات بسيطه جدا
غير متوفره
اليات بسيطه
انا انا ساعطيك نموذجا خالد هذه البنايه
التي ستشاهدها الان يحدث فيها الامر الذي
سالت انت عنه الان هنالك اعتقاد بان هنالك
احياء داخل هذه البنايه ساقترب قليلا انا
وزميل المصور
اليات الثقيله في هذا المبنى توقفت عن
العمل خالد لانه يبدو انهم قد سمعوا صوتا
لشخص لا يزال على قيد الحياه تحت هذه
البنايه وبالتالي لذلك توقفت الاليات
الثقيله الان تبدا العمليه الجراحيه يعني
هي تشبه العمليه الجراحيه فعلا من دقتها
لانه هذا الشخص الذي لا يزال على قيد
الحياه انت تحتاج ان تتعامل مع هذا الركام
وهذه الكتل الخرسانيه الكبيره والاسقف
بهدوء وشديد جدا حتى تحافظ على حياته ان
كان لا يزال على قيد الحياه هذه انا ساقطع
يعني ساطلب من الزميل مصور ان يقترب ان
كنت تشاهد هم يعني يتجمعون في نقطه ما حيث
يعني كان هنالك صوت لشخص لا يزال على قيد
الحياه بالتالي
طبعا دائما هنالك امل وكما قلت انت الان
انه طبعا مع مرور زياده عدد الايام او
الساعات منذ بدء الزلزال تقل فرصه يعني
وجود ناجين ولكن لا تزال حتى هذه اللحظه
هذا نموذج يحدث امامك الان طبعا دمار هائل
في كل مكان في بنايات كثيره الاسر دائما
من لديه شخص تحت الانقاد دائما لديه امل
بانه لا يزال على قيد الحياه ولكن هناك
فرق متخصصه في حال سمعوا صوتا لشخص من
الناجين تبدا فعلا تتوقف الاليات الثقيله
عن العمل تبدا عمليات بسيطه يدويه كما
تشاهدون لك الان تبدا عمليات يدويه يعني
بالفاس وازاله الانقاض بشكل
بسيط وسهل وتدريجي حتى يصلوا الى هذا
الشخص الذي لا يزال على قيد الحياه هنالك
نعم نقص في اعداد
المتطوعين او العاملين
من فرق الانقاذ لانه الدمار هائل يعني هم
لماذا يعني طلبوا المساعده ويطلبون
المساعده لانه الدمار هائل جدا في كل مكان
هذا المشهد يعني يتكرر في اضنه يتكرر في
كل المدن التي شهدت هذا
وتاثرت بهذا الزلزال وتاثرت بالهزات
الارتداديه التي لا تزال تحدث هنالك طبعا
كمان خالد خوف كبير من هذه الهزات
الارتداديه كما قلت لك وهنالك خوف ان يكون
هنالك زلزال اخر هم الناس خائفون جدا
وبالتالي من يستطيع ان يخلي هذه المنطقه
وليس لديه احد تحت الانقاد قام
بمغادرتها اما انه توجه الى الخيام التي
وفرتها الحكومه التركيه طبعا ولا تتسع
لالاف المواطنين ولكن يعني انعثر على مكان
او ان ينتقل الى مدينه اخرى الى حيث
اقاربه يستطيع ان يبقى عندها عندهم بالامس
ليلا كانت يعني هنالك محاولات لاخراج شاب
كان يعتقد انه لا يعني لا يزال حي ولكنني
علمت ولست متاكده من الخبر علمت بانه
للاسف الشديد يعني فارق الحياه بعد عمليه
صبر كانت استمرت لساعات هنا في مبنى مجاور
لانهم كانوا يستمعون الى صوت كانوا يطلبوا
من هذا الشاب ان يدق او يضرب على شيء في
حال يسمعهم وبالفعل في بدايه الامر كان
يدق ويضرب على اشياء سمعوا صوتها وكان
يجيبهم من خلال الدق ولكن بعد ذلك توقف
هذا الامر ويعني للاسف كان قد فارق الحياه
وبالتالي هذا نموذج امام خالد والسؤال مهم
جدا فعلا انه يعني ماذا سيفعل ستفعل كل
فرق الانقاذ هذه وكل هذه هذا الحشد
لامكانيات مقابل شخص لا يزال تحت الانقاض
لا يريد اي شيء سوى ان يسمعه احد او يخرجه
احد والوقت يمر ويداهم الجميع وليس في
صالح يعني من هم تحت الانقاض ومن يعملون
لانه الامر محزن للغايه سنبقى نحن يعني في
هاتاي هذا المشهد هنالك مشاهد اخرى وهنالك
حالات اخرى للبحث عن ناجين ولكن كما قلت
لك اليوم لم يسجل اخراج اي ناجين في في
ولايه هاتاي وللاسف يعني كان هنالك يعني
اخراج عدد كبير من الجثيمين من تحت
الانقاض ونقلها مباشره الى المستشفيات
ومعظمها ينتقل الى مدينه اضنه وحتى اذا
كان هنالك يعني
جرحك جميعهم كانوا ينقلوا الى مستشفيات
مدينه اضنه لانه في هذا الشارع كما قلت لك
كان هنالك مستشفى خاص مثلا تدمر بالكامل
وعمليات الانقاذ او الرفع الانقاذ منه
تجري الان على قدم وساق الدمار خالد كبير
حجم الدمار كبير جدا مهما كانت الامكانيات
التي لديهم ومهما كانت المساعدات وكما قلت
لك هناك طائرات عسكريه وهنالك طبعا
عناصر الجيش وعناصر الامن والدفاع المدني
واضح احمر ومتطوعين ومدنيين وكل يشارك في
هذا الامر ولكن كما قلت لك العمليه معق
جدا تشبه عمليه جراحيه معقده جدا جدا جدا
وتحتاج يعني الى صبر كبير اما شكرا جزيلا
لك سنتابع معك في تغطيتنا في نشرتنا لاحقا
شكرا ايضا لزيدان زنكرو الذي كان معنا من
اضنه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في سوريا المجاوره ارتفعت حصيله ضحايا
زلزال القرن لاكثر من 2500 قتيل والاصابات
تخطت الخمسه الاف اجراء زلزال وتوابعه وقد
فادت منظمه الخوذ البيضاء ارتفاع بارتفاع
حصيله قتل الزلزال المدمر في شمال غرب
سوريا لنحو 1300 قتيل واكد اعلام نظام
السوري ان هزه ارضيه خفيفه شعر بها سكان
اللاذقيه والطرطوس وحلب وحمص صباحا
في مدينه حلب المنكوب فادت التقارير بانها
كانت الاكثر التضرعا
[موسيقى]
وفي ظل معاناه عدد من المدن السوريه
المتضرره من نقص المساعدات الانسانيه بسبب
صعوبه وصولهم اليها جوائز زلزال القرن
ارسل اهالي مدينه الباب مساعدات داخليه
الى اهالي بلده جنديرس في حلب المتضرره
[موسيقى]
وفي مدينه سلقين في غرب مقطع فيديو لحظات
انقاذ رجل على قيد الحياه من تحت انقاضي
مبنى مدمر في المدينه وذلك بعد اكثر من 24
ساعه من الزلزال العنيق الذي ضرب مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
جمعه مرحبا بك
الانباء او اخر الارقام تتحدث عن ارتفاع
ايضا في اعداد القتلى وكذلك الجرحى في
الاراضي السوريه يعني انت كيف تتابع
المشهد من هناك
صحيح خالد اعداد القت
في ارتفاع متواصل الدفاع المدني المسؤوله
عن مناطق المعادله رفعت حصيله القتلى الى
حوالي 1270 بما اننا نتحدث عن 1300
في مناطق المعارضه وتحديدا في ادلب والياف
حلب الاقارب وجنديرس يتصدران المشهد بعد
ان يعني تقريبا
اتضحت الصوره اكثر في الاتارب اليوم
الازار تتجه الى بلده جنديرس المنكوبه
بالكامل والتي تحاول فرق الانقاذ يعني
الوصول الى مصادر الاصوات التي تخرج من
تحت الامراض والمباني هذه البلده تعيش
حاله كارثيه والان هناك يعني اهتمام من
مناطق المعارضه بهذه البلده الدفاع المدني
او حتى من الفراق من الفصائل العسكريه
وايضا
هناك محاولات من يعني مساعدات من سكان
مدينه الباب مساعدات من الاهالي مساعدات
الجماعيه ايضا هناك مبادرات فرديه بالذهاب
يعني عشرات الى شباب من المناطق المجاوره
الى جنديرس لمساعده عمال الانقاذ والفرق
في رفع القاضي يعني مبنى مدمر في جنديرس
وصلوا الى حاليا الى حوالي عشرين مبنى من
اصل من اصل هذه العدد الكبير عشرات
الاشخاص يزالون عناقين في جنديرس تحت
الارقاد وكلما مر الوقت تتضاء الفرص
للعثور على احياء من بينهم
هل سجلت اي مساعدات وصلت
وشاهدت رصدت مساعدات وصلت الى المناطق
السوريه المتضرره
يعني رغم مرور هذه
الساعات الطويله على وقوع الكارثه لم نسجل
وصول اي مساعدات ملموسه الى المناطق
الخاضعه للسيارات المعارضه السوريه حتى
الان رغم انه العديد من الدول العربيه
ارسلت طائرات وصلت الى مطار دمشق وبعضها
الى مطار حلب الدولي هذه المساعدات على ما
يبدو تاج هذه المناطق المنسوبه في
اللاذقيه
وجبله وطرطوس وحمى لكنها لم تدخل الى
المناطق التي تقرا عليها
دوران نتحدث عن جزء كبير من ارياف حلب
طيب شكرا جزيلا لك اذا المراسل العربيه يا
جماعه كاش كان معنا من القامشلي سنتابع
معك بالتاكيد تطورات لاحقا خلال هذه
التغطيه نذهب الان الى
القاهره الى مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن سيد رامي اهلا
وسهلا بك
الان التقارير التي تصلكم عن حجم هذه
الكارثه حجم المعاناه ايضا والدمار
ومدى قدره القوه البيضاء واهل المنطقه على
التعامل مع هذه الاوضاع الماساويه والدمار
الكبير ماذا تقول هذه التقرير
نعم يعني صباح الخير مجددا بالنسبه نبدا
بالخسائر البشريه حصيله النظام التي اعلنا
الان وشاهدنا العربيه هذه حصيله مساء
الامس التي نشرها المرصد عندما تحدث عن
2500 في مناطق النظام ومناطق المعارضه
هناك خسائر اكبر من الرقم الذي نشره
المرصد قبل قليل على العربيه
2751 الى الان هذا الرقم المؤكد والرقم
الحقيقي اكبر من ذلك بكثير نعود الى
التقارير عندما كنت اشاهد يعني مطولا ماذا
يجري في اضنه وان هناك عشرات من الفرق
المختصه تقوم بمحاوله انقاذ من هم تحت
مبنى بينما نحن نشاهد عشرات المباني التي
هي مدمره ومحطمه في جنديرس يوجد بعض
العناصر من الدفاع المدني الذين يحاولون
مساعده هؤلاء السوريين ويوجد بعض المدنيين
الذين يحاولون مساعده هؤلاء السوريين تحت
الانقاذ دون ان يتمكنوا من انقاذهم لماذا
لان لا يوجد فرق مخت موجوده على الاراضي
السوريه تستطيع مساعده الذين لا يزلون تحت
انقاض المباني المهدمه يعني اقول لك ايضا
هناك قرى وصلنا اليها كان فيها على سبيل
المثال قريه في ريف سراقب كان فيها نحو 20
شخص
قتلوا تم دفنهم دون الاعلان عنهم دون
الابلاغ احد بان هناك قتله كانوا نتيجه
الزلزال في تلك المنطقه اي ان الخسائر
البشريه هي كبيره وكبيره جدا عندما تهدا
الامور سوف نشاهد بان حصيله يعني القسائر
البشريه قد تصل ليس الى 3000 مثل ما اعلنا
امس قد تفوق الاربعه الاف سوري لان فقط في
اللاذقيه وجبله الى الان نحو 700 قتلوا في
هذه المنطقه من الساحه السوري وايضا هناك
المئات قتلوا في حلب في مناطق النظام
بينما في جنديرس لوحدها نعيد ونذكر
بجنديرس لماذا لان الكثير مثل ما قال
الجمعه الكثير من المنازل لم تصلها تتمكن
الفرق الانقاذ او الفرق الدفاع المدني من
الوصول الى هذه المنازل هم وصلوا الى 12
منزلا الى ما يفيد قليلا اقل قليلا ولكن
الارقام هي كبيره جدا وفي شنتيرس لوحدها
قد يصل العدد الى نحو 900 او الى الف
حقيقه الامر لان العدد الحالي حتى اللحظه
في هذه البلده الصغيره فاقه 680 سوريا
وقتلوا تحت الانقاض او قتلوا بعد وصولهم
الى المشافي ارقام مهوله يعني وضع ماثاوي
كارثه اليات كثيره موجوده شاهدناها في
تركيا اليات ليست كثيره وليست قليله يعني
بضعه اليات ليست يعني بطريقه بدائيه في
محاوله للمساعده لا يوجد اليات لا يوجد
اليات نستطيع يعني ازاله الانقاض الا بشكل
بدائي او حتى بعض الاليات الموجوده للدفاع
المدني او حتى بعد بعض الاليات الموجوده
لدى يعني المقاولين الذين يعملون في
البناء يستخدمون الياتهم هذه قد تتسبب
بمقتل من هم على قيد الحياه تحت الانقاذ
في حال لم يكن هناك متخصصين بقضيه التعامل
مع هذه الكوارث الانسانيه وما زالت كل
المعابر مغلقه سيد رامي يتحدث عن معبر
ربما عن معابر اخرى بديله يمكن استغلالها
في هذه الحاله يعني
يا سيدي الكريم يوجد معبر جرابلس معبر
الراعي معبر
في المعابر موجوده يعني تستطيع يستطيع
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يفعل شيء وايضا يوجد
دليل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مناطق
سيطره قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تستطيع
ارسال مساعدات الى هذه المناطق المنكوبه
وضع كارثه تتحدث انت تقول يعني كل دقائق
كل ساعه تتحدث عن الارقام جديده المؤكد
لدينا نحن الان لا ننشر الرقم المؤكد
لدينا بان هناك اكثر من 3,000 شخص
احصاء بعض القرى الموجوده المتناثره شكرا
جزيلا لك رامي عبد الرحمن مدير المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان كنت معي من القاهره
نتابع هذه الارقام الاخيره حسب المرصد
السوري ارتفاع حصيره قتل الزلزال في سوريا
الى 2751
تغطيه هنا مستمره الى دبي الان الزميل
نادين خمش